hello this is Olivia Megaton I did not
like your review of Columbiana I hope
you liked akin to you hack I'm only
going to say this once
I have a particular set of skills
film critiquing skills skills to make me
a nightmare for people like you if you
stop now I will not pursue you but if
you keep making sequels to successful
action franchises that suck ass I will
pursue you I will find you and I will
rip your movie a new asshole I adored
taken I love this movie I thought it was
such a big surprise it came out in
January when most films aren't very good
it was kind of the movie that really
propelled Liam Neeson as an action star
because he did action before that you
know he was in Star Wars he was in
Batman Begins no Rob Roy he did action
roles before that but this is really the
movie that started the whole I'm Liam
Neeson and I will kill you with my
pinkie thing you know taken two stars
Liam Neeson fomka Jensen Maggie Grace
and the nice coat guy from Batman Begins
as the main villain oliviere Megaton
Megaton Oliver Megaton I don't know how
to say his name but he directed this
movie he also made transporter 3 and
Columbiana two films with some of the
worst film to action I've ever seen and
when I heard they were making a movie
just flat-out called taken two I just
thought it was dumb I mean I mean it
just felt like a very unnecessary sequel
it just didn't seem like there was a
point to this movie except cash-grab and
this movie Liam Neeson and his family
are on vacation in Istanbul and the
people whose family members were killed
in the first film come back for revenge
on Liam Neeson in this film that's an
it's like I okay I see it you know I see
how that could be fun if you can tell by
my intro and how I'm speaking right now
I wasn't really a fan of this movie Liam
Neeson is effortlessly watchable I mean
that guy adds credibility to anything he
is such a good actor and he was good in
this movie of course and he's a likeable
actor and you want to see him in movies
you want to see him you let you just
like Liam Neeson he's awesome and he is
by far the best part of this movie
lost the realistic sense of the first
film the first film felt like okay this
guy truly is a master spy assassin who
could kill me just by looking at me I
mean you just you bought that in this
film this film feels like a movie when
two characters burst through a room and
they're about to fight they're magically
in some beautiful Cathedral and they're
standing on top of some fountain in this
giant video game esque surrounding area
that looks like something out of a kung
fu movie this movie feels like a
production it feels like this is all
made up this is fake this is all set up
to look like a big fancy Hollywood
affair Maggie grace um you know I just I
don't buy her as an actress I don't
think she's a good actress I'm sorry
she's she's bad in this movie as she
overact in every shot and that could be
the directors fault for telling her to
act that way fomka Jensen wasn't
over-the-top Liam Neeson wasn't
over-the-top this girl was just so off
the wall in this movie with acting and
the crying and the crying and the
screaming and the crying here's the
problem okay and I knew this going in
the action is so poorly filmed I would
say the median length of a shot in this
movie is perhaps less than a second
there is so many cuts in this movie and
you just can't tell what's going on and
the sound effects are so quiet that it
sometimes there actually aren't sound
effects for the hits and the crunches
and it looks like Liam Neeson is just
performing some sort of elaborate
chiropractic adjustment on the villains
rather than actually fighting them and
it just didn't have that sense of fun
the first film had because you couldn't
tell what was going on it's just it's
filmed to crap I don't understand why
this director keeps filming fight scenes
that are so horrible I mean just rewatch
the end fight scene in Columbiana
it'll give you a migraine it's so poorly
filmed and it's the same in this movie
this guy seems to think that the more
shots and angles you get of one punch
the better it's just like dude show it
happening these actors practice the
choreography just don't cut so much and
zoom in and use you know like post
effects to make the shots look different
it's terrible the villain in the movie
is extremely weak he tells all these
threats to Liam Neeson and to Liam
Neeson's family and then he leaves the
rumen has other people do it for him and
it's like dude get your hands dirty do
something I mean he just he just walks
around and makes threats he's a terrible
villain when you're watching the movie
it's like it's not boring okay cuz it's
basically from about a half-hour on an
endless array of chases and
interrogations and fights and running
talking on the phone and making up
little MacGyver like gadgets to get out
of situations and you know for that
reason it's not boring it's just it gets
really monotonous after a while when
it's filmed so horribly and when the
story is just so silly and over-the-top
like he actually tells Maggie grace to
take grenades and just throw them out
into the city so we can listen for the
sound of the grenade to figure out how
far away they are okay I get that but
you're telling your daughter to throw
grenades off of a roof you're gonna
explode a baby or something eventually I
mean seriously man just I don't
understand who I don't know there's
something in this movie that really
ticked me off all right now it might not
bother all people but it really got
under my skin
there's a scene in the movie where
Maggie Grace is listening to a song and
her headphones and she's dancing around
it's the real human being song from
Drive and I was thinking would you
really want to put that in your movie I
mean it's basically renowned as the
theme song for drive now but I'm willing
to forget that all right okay whatever
so she was listening to a Drive song
okay literally ten minutes later a
second song from the Drive soundtrack
appears in the film the chromatics take
up the clock and it just got me thinking
wow these people really liked the Drive
soundtrack they really listened to that
soundtrack and thought wow this would
really be cool in our movie wouldn't it
the movie that came out exactly last
year in September we need to use songs
from that soundtrack because our movie
isn't very good it just got under my
skin that it was so obviously popped in
the Drive soundtrack and were like yeah
we need to use some of these songs don't
put those in your movie no no those
that's Drive music now that's that's
just that's not no the action is just
poorly filmed the story is uninteresting
and silly and over-the-top the only
saving grace in this movie is the added
credibility of Liam Neeson which he
always gives to his roles I really want
this director to stop directing action
movies they're not good he's not good at
it stop there are plenty of people out
there who can do it better so
unfortunately I didn't enjoy
- very much I'm going to give taken to a
see - but were you really surprised I
mean it's just it's just a sequel that's
like really do we really need this so
here's a question for you what do you
think is one of the most unnecessary
sequels ever thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this and
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]